on the topic of the Queen speech I'd
like to ask you James it is about what
you thought of it what was announced
what were the high points and low points
I mean this Queen speech was designed to
deflect the charge this is a zombie
Hallman it's the government trying to
show that it still got things if it
wants to do I think that these
legislators probably make the most
difference is this human trafficking
bill but there were not some kind of
symbolic things and values this kind of
heroism bill design so you know if you
go and try and rescue someone at scene
of an accident you can't then be
prosecuted if your if your action the
inadvertently caused harm to somebody
else I mean that's a bit of common sense
it's meant to show people that they
could have listened some of the concerns
that drama if you keep driving people of
the UK probably know that no but there's
no common sense in the country anymore I
mean there's also a bit of a part of
Cameron you can have empty bossiness
beam this stuff in a small business bill
the you know you're having at your have
an appeals regulator who basically will
say to any over-over mighty regulators
picking on small businesses back off and
also this statutory commitment on
government to deregulate it's about do
you think it successfully passed away
the charges this is a zombie government
I think it probably has given emplyees
enough to talk about and there are as
James says radical bits of legislation
in there so there's slavery bill but
also pensions reforms as well but the
problem is it's not as radical as the
coalition has been and it's a shame that
it's last year isn't as radical and
that's partly because actually they took
out fives from Tony Blair and tried to
get the really big things done quickly
but the problem is is a lot of the
legislation is sort of Pro nice and
Auntie bad
it's the heroism bill which actually
sounds lovely but it's a bit like one of
those bills that protects homeowners who
intervene when a burglar gets into their
property and that sort of thing it's the
sign of a Chris Grayling speciality yeah
yeah it's mostly a part of it but the
fact they've called it the heroism bill
is quite cheesy as well as my grandiose
isn't clearly a sort of PR exercises as
much as anything else I mean it's what
I'm taking moment of reflect that isn't
there was there was something very good
about the well constitutional functions
it is a reminder that the
monarch is subservient to Parliament as
a reminder that the pollen one must or
more I'm active absolutely crucial we
should never forget about who's quite
funny hearing the Queen she didn't quite
say hard-working people I think but she
did definitely have to say this
governments long term he cannot make a
stronger economy and fairer society I
think everyone is still transfixed by
the immense success of in New Labour's
first Queen speech they have I won't
attempt to imitate the Queen but they
have the Queen say my government was
elected as new labor and will governance
new labor and this wasn't the first time
the queen of it said something isn't
quite so explicitly political I'm so
explicitly kind of on message in that
way and it was incredibly effective
because these clips of a queen are
played on the news in a way that David
Cameron or Nick Clegg saying it isn't
Nick like I said stronger economy fairer
society can have more time so we've all
had hot dinners collectively but we all
kind of tuned it out but the Queen
saying gives it much light and
authenticity yeah
were there any surprises it's a bad
thing that we weren't expecting that
popped up in there no major surprises I
think one of the big surprises today is
being completely unconnected to the
Queen speak which is the vowel over
extremism between Michael grade and
Theresa May which will distract from the
radical legislation that they do want to
highlight how much do you think that's
going to overshadow in sort of the news
bulletins and papers tomorrow
well it's a rouse always much more
interesting than something nice that the
people will have introduced a recurring
speech so I can imagine that if both
sides decide to continue briefing which
I think Dan's read quite keen not to
they should a statement stay from a
spokesperson for Michael Gove an therese
of any which is a role that doesn't
actually exist but it's clearly been
created today so they're clearly keen to
stamp it out but if that does continue
in some way with allies briefing then it
will be a much bigger story
there's a definite attempt to calm
things down today some of these people
closest to Michael Gove turn their
phones off my clothes former adviser
doorman Cummings is said to tweet
declaring he's got no coin to make he's
supervising building works and he's not
going to get involved in this rail I
don't think one of the things that the
it has made this radix explode so much
is that lots of trees amaze allies have
long disliked the fact that lots of
those who admire Michael go see them as
in love the logical next step in his
career has been a it's been there's Tory
Roy Jenkins the great reformer in Home
Secretary going books he has incredibly
strong views on a hole in Islamic
extremism question would pit him could
have directly against Charles Fong who
is one of treasom a source servants at
the Home Office and you know he's so
close to the main circle for these that
he's dating one of her aides and so I
mean this is one of the things that
makes it all so volatile and so
explosive and that is my feet number 10
I've kind of tried everything they can
to calm the Ralphs down today
and finally as well do you think you
could describe this Queen speeches as a
coalition for like you know is it gonna
equal sausage ingredients or whatever
the analogy is between the air between
the two parties well I think it is and
there aren't any there aren't any bits
of legislation in there that they're
going to be carrying majorly but there
was obviously horse trading beforehand
which I think some of the horse trading
will emerge and some of it already has
but but it's a speech around which they
can unite because most of it's the sort
of thing you couldn't really argue with
a lot of it's motherhood and apple pie
yeah now the only bit James in
particular that you think you could see
where the horse trading has gone on only
the seal on the fracking stuff and you
can see on the waters they will always
be remembered for one of those
disastrous verticals of recent times the
stuff on public or something like that
I mean who ever fought in the Lib Dems
like the understanding that they've been
driven to drink but Nick Clegg and Vince
Cable turning up in a pub at 11:00 a.m.
what was this slightly dramatic it was
Charlie Kennedy days are back it was and
so I mean that we know that that is
where there's been a bit of horse
trading I do you think that one of the
remarkable things about the question
that we don't actually have enough he's
a they've still got some legislative
agenda in the last row Department many
people including myself for but 2014
would be the year when the curtain began
to be wound down and there was some kind
of number for more distance look between
the parties it doesn't look like that's
going to happen also I mean you watch
the politician saunter through together
it's very big what's your camera in the
middle I'm trying to talk with Nick Lane
and Harry Hall
when they got to the Lord's Nick
collected a bunch of his way to stand in
the front road enforces a reinforce his
thesis as a party leader and he seemed
to look towards camera and he did you to
see whatever the brows are they have
themselves have had between them they
still pleaded get on better with each
other than either get on the blade and
that I think could be that personal
chemistry could be very important if the
next election produces another
indeterminate result